>> Greg: OF PHILLY JUDGE
PROVES SHE ROCKS BY FREEING
COLUMBUS FROM HIS STUPID BOX.
PHILADELPHIA, THE BIRTHPLACE OF
THE WEDGING GYM, HAS REMOVED A
PLYWOOD BOX MAY BE COVERING UP
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS STATUE FOR
THE TWO YEARS.
AFTER A JUDGE RULED I HAD TO BE
TAKEN DOWN.
THEY NEED THE WOOD TO COVER
VACANT STORE WINDOWS.
OR AS THEY COLLECT IN PHILLY,
NEW CRACK HOUSE.
OLD CHRIS HAD BEEN COVERED SINCE
THE RIOTS OF 2020.
HE IS ON THE LEFT.
WHEN PHILLY MAYOR JIM KENNEY
ORDERED THE STATUES REMOVAL
CALLING IT A MATTER OF PUBLIC
SAFETY, APPARENTLY WAS THE ONLY
WAY TO KEEP COLUMBUS FROM
GETTING MUGGED.
BUT APPARENTLY DELUSIONAL
ACTIVISTS FEARED THE MONUMENT
ITSELF COULD PUT LIVES IN
DANGER.
IN CASE THE STATUE COMES TO
LIFE.
LIKE AL GORE DID.
BUT THE CITY COULDN'T GET THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO DO THAT SO
THEY BOXED IT UP AND IT HAS BEEN
A LEGAL FIGHT EVER SINCE.
POOR CC HAS BEEN SITTING IN A
BOX LIKE IT'S GWYNETH PALTROW'S
SEVERED HEAD.
I KNOW.
AND THAT WAS FICTION.
BUMMER.
NOW IT SEEMS LIKE THE YEARS OF
ANTI-STATUE HYSTERIA ARE OVER
WITH THIS LATEST RULING, THE
JUDGE SAYS THE CITY DISAGREES
WITH THE MESSAGE, THE STATUE
SENDS CONNECTICUT AT ITS OWN
PLAQUE WITH WHAT IT WANTS TO
CONVEY WHICH LIKELY WON'T HAPPEN
SINCE IT REQUIRES REAL WORK IN
PHILLY OUTLAWED THAT YEARS AGO.
I WOULD WANT THE PRESIDENT TAKES
ABOUT ALL THIS.
>> NO, NO, NO, THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE DOWN THE
STATUE.
THEY PUT IT IN A BOX.
HE PUT THINGS IN BOXES THAT YOU
LIKE.
LIKE THIS RIGHT HERE.
SEE THIS BOX?
IT'S A GIFT FOR JILL.
IT'S A NUTCRACKER GUY.
NUTCRACKER THINKS HE'S A TOUGH
GUY.
♪♪ DID YOU KNOW THAT I COULD
KICK YOUR ASS ♪
♪ NO, YOU DON'T ♪
♪ YOU WILL GO DOWN JUST LIKE
CORN PROMPTED ♪♪
>> Greg: PHILADELPHIA COVERED
THE STATUE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
IF THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THAT,
WHY NOT PUT A BOX AROUND
PHILADELPHIA?
MAYBE WE GOT IT WRONG.
MAYBE WE NEED TO PUT BOXES
AROUND MORE THINGS.
>> HONESTLY PHILADELPHIA HAS
INSPIRED ME.
COVERING THINGS UP JUST BECAUSE
SOME PEOPLE CONSIDER THEM
OFFENSIVE IS WRONG.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE THIS RIGHT.
YOU GUYS, THANK YOU.
NOBODY OPEN ME UP INTO YEARS.
NOW I KNOW IT'S LIKE TO BE ONE
OF GUTFELD'S BOOKS.
>> Greg: THAT STUPID, STUPID
SKIT, JUST USE TO INSULT ME.
BECAUSE IT'S THE HOLIDAY SPIRIT,
I'M GOING TO PRETEND LIKE IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BOY, DOES THAT PISS ME OFF.
HAROLD, WE WERE IN THE GREEN
ROOM AND USE THAT I'M SO HAPPY
WE ARE BRINGING CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS BACK.
EXTREMELY UNDERRATED EXPLORER
AND ALL-AROUND GREAT GUY WHO GOT
UNFAIRLY MALIGNED BY THE BIASED
LIBERAL MEDIA OF THE 1700s.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
>> Harold: I DON'T KNOW IF I
SET IT LIKE THAT.
I DO THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN COLUMBUS AND THE FOLKS
THAT FOUGHT, YOU KNOW, FIGHTING
TO KEEP BLACKS AND OTHERS
ENSLAVED.
CHRISTOPHER COMBS, I'VE NEVER
BEEN A BIG BELIEVER IN NOT
TELLING HIS STORY.
THERE'S A FULLNESS TO THE STORY.
YOU'D NECESSARILY WANTED TO HOLD
THE WEIGHT WAS TOLD WE SHOULD
EDUCATE AMERICA, EDUCATE YOUNG
PEOPLE ALIKE.
ABOUT THE BIRTH OF THE COUNTRY
AND HOW HE WAS A PART OF HELPING
TO DECLARE THAT THIS WAS A LAND,
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE PEOPLE
LIVING HERE BEFORE.
I CALL IT COLUMBUS DAY.
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE, IT TAKES TOO
MUCH TIME TO SAY INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES' DAY.
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS IS PART OF
OUR HISTORY.
WE SHOULDN'T BE AFRAID.
NOR SHOULD WE BE AFRAID TO TALK
ABOUT NATIVE AMERICANS THAT WERE
HERE BEFORE.
SO I HOPE PHILLY AND EVERY CITY
IS ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> Greg: IT IS EITHER TO SAY
COLUMBUS TRUNK THAN INDIGENOUS.
>> Harold: YOU COULD GET
YOURSELF IN TROUBLE.
>> Greg: I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING IN NEW YORK THAT YOU
WANT TO PUT IN A BOX.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> Kat: THE CHRISTMAS TREE.
I JUST WANT TO MOVE IT TO
STATEN ISLAND.
>> Greg: I AM WITH YOU.
HONESTLY, THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
THAN NEW YORK AND THE
ROCKEFELLER CHRISTMAS TREE.
THE MOST ANTI-HOLIDAY THING THAT
HAS EVER BEEN DONE.
HE DRIVES PEOPLE TO CRIMINALITY.
>> Kat: I BELIEVE THAT.
LET'S GO WITH THAT.
>> Greg: NO ONE'S REALLY ANGRY
AT COLUMBUS.
>> Kat: I AM.
I AM PISSED WHEN I SEE STATUES
OF COLUMBUS.
I GET LOST ALL THE TIME AND I'VE
GOT NO STATUES.
I HAVE GOTTEN LOST I WOULD SAY A
LOT MORE TIMES THAN THIS GUY.
I DON'T HAVE A DAY NAMED FOR ME.
NOT EVEN IN MY OWN COUNTRY.
ENOUGH.
>> Greg: SO YOU'RE SAYING GET
RID OF IT?
>> Kat: HE GOT LOST.
WE ARE LIKE, "AMAZING."
THAT'S A SIMPLE VERSION OF THE
STORY.
>> Greg: GOD, I WISH I HAD YOU
IN MY HISTORY CLASS.
MORGAN, YOU KNOW IT'S
INTERESTING, WHEN YOU LOOK BACK,
IT'S TWO YEARS AGO MAYBE
WHATEVER, DOESN'T IT SEEM LIKE A
WEIRD KIND OF PERIOD OF
DELUSION?
PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND KNOCKING
DOWN STATUES.
AND THEN IT JUST STOPPED.
IT'S LIKE --
IT WAS LIKE A PURGING AND WE
NEVER TALK ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
IT'S SO STRANGE.
>> Morgan: IT'S BECAUSE BIDEN
GOT ELECTED.
THE STATUES AREN'T A PROBLEM
ANYMORE.
THERE'S BEEN AT LEAST 488
HOMICIDES IN PHILADELPHIA THIS
YEAR.
FROM 2015 TO 2021, OVERDOSES
WENT UP 100%.
YOU WOULD THINK THE THIEF PHILLY
MAYOR WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
BUSIER WITH OTHER THINGS IN
STATUES AND BOXES.
I'M ALSO REALLY CURIOUS TO KNOW
HOW MANY GOVERNMENT WORKERS
ATTEMPT TO REMOVE THAT BOX.
HOW MANY UNIONIZED WORKERS IT
TOOK, A PRETTY PENNY FOR THE
PHILADELPHIA TAXPAYER.
>> Greg: JIM, YOU'RE A WIDELY
RESPECTED HISTORIAN AND SELF
ABUSER.
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT THIS
PERIOD, WHAT STRIKES YOU ABOUT
THIS ATTACK ON OUR NATION'S
FOUNDER?
>> Jim: I'VE HAD ENOUGH OF
COLUMBUS.
I HATE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COVER
THE STATUE AND I HATE PEOPLE
UPSET THAT THE STATUE WAS
COVERED.
I DON'T CARE.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS
CULTURALLY, PEOPLE THINK IT'S A
DIRECT REFLECTION ON THEM.
IT'S NOT.
THIS STATUE STINKS.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S WEARING YOGA
PANTS AND A DRESS.
IT'S AN UGLY STATUE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
HIS HAIR CUT STINKS.
IT'S A DUMB LUCK.
I DON'T CARE.
I DON'T GET ANY ANGER ABOUT IT
AND I DON'T GET ANY GOOD
FEELINGS.
IT'S NOT A REFLECTION OF JIM
NORTON.
MEANINGLESS FIGHT.
EVERYONE JUST WANTS TO PUT THEIR
STINK ON SOMETHING.
THEY WANT TO FEEL LIKE THEY MOVE
THE NEEDLE A LITTLE BIT.
WHO CARES.
>> Greg: NO ONE REALLY IS
ANGRY ABOUT THIS.
>> Jim: DO YOU KNOW WHY BIRDS
[BLEEP]
ON STATUES?
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALLOWED TO.
THAT'S WHY THEY DO.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING WISER HAS EVER BE